I've lied to my girlfriend about not
having a drug overdose when I did to
make her feel better I pretended to be
religious so that my choir teacher would
like me more and give me a solo she's
religious do you feel bad about it at
all I mean I got the solo I took
necklace
to give to an ex necklace belongs to my
mom which one I gave to and now I lost
that I've given up my best friend to my
best friend was having problems my plane
and she was calling her name so I had a
sacrifice of friendship
have a good
I flew one thousand and two hundred
miles to hang out with my friend today
and she canceled on me I used to when my
next and I would get in fights I've put
time bags of weed alike try to get him
back
I thought live lobsters at the airport
to fly home for my parents but I had
such a long flight delay that I ended up
naming them I really had tact so when I
brought them home for my parents and I
took a shower I came back out and they
were already cooked it was really
emotionally stressful so I basically
gave up my new pet lobsters for my
parents meal love you mom and dad my mom
usually that's to take a lot of pictures
all places like in the Starbucks or a
restaurant run them places and I don't
like I don't like it and I do it just to
please her just to make her happy
I was shrieking outside of my house
making my sister character oh yeah I was
full nude so the only thing I can really
think of is like when you're talking
[ __ ] about someone else because it's
gonna make your friend feel better
[Music]
tonight I really don't feel that bad the
worst thing I did to make someone else
happy it was back when I went to United
States Marine Corps boot camp joseki at
the time told me that I needed to steal
actually camis because my friend my
other recruit lost his camouflage
utility uniform so at night sometime
between like 2:00 to 3:00 a.m. I snuck
out I went to someone else's laundry
room
check the academy's and take it to my
friends so now I don't know who you are
I'm sorry for silly Kevin [ __ ] sorry for
stealing your candies but it made my
platoon very happy I don't know what
happened to you but I hope you do ok now
I was living with two girls in Rio de
Janeiro and the bath was clogged and I
had to clean the thing with a fork in
them it was full of hair and it was so
disgusting I remember even today I can I
can imagine it this time in my life
because I was doing to place my friends
at the time and it was the worst moment
I think living with them I got all my
money out of my bank account and I went
to a festival that I built some one out
of jail and
yeah and they were really happy and they
were free and then I almost got evicted
my children when we were skiing in
Switzerland I went down a mobile field
and was scared to death and thought it
would never be over but I went down for
them back in college
no yeah College I was really poor and
sheep so I would download a bunch of
films all the time as everyone does and
not pay for them as everyone does in the
early internet and I downloaded it with
the word computer it was Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world it's great movies you
watch it and because a co-worker wanted
to see it oh yeah I'll get it for you
and I start the download at my house and
the download finish that might work a
company network and end up getting
downloaded and noticed by our RT
Department and then Sony Pictures and I
was let go for my job because of it oh
no and I never told them that i download
the movie for it because i just didn't
want to deal with at that point and also
i got fired so i'd never got to talk to
him afterwards
something that I've done to make someone
else happy
I guess tolerate abuse I was in a really
emotional physical abusive relationship
so I took crap from him and his family
all at once what I did was kind of like
take all the problems out on me and
started thinking like yeah maybe it is
my fault
yeah maybe I you know should have done
this differently I kind of closed myself
off to my own emotions and kind of
forgot where I came from I didn't want
to lose my roots and to forget about the
strong women in my family due to other
women in another person's family so yeah
I guess that's something I've to
I'm like being on their time and at my
own time and then time just gets wasted
it's probably like the worst thing can't
get it back stay in a relationship
longer than I needed to to make them
feel safe and secure when all I really
wanted to do was be free and liberated
from them I feel like I've sacrificed my
sanity quite a few times like I'll
pretend like I'm not mad when I'm
actually pissed off just to like make
them happy or to like save their
feelings or whatever but I've forgotten
myself you know sometimes in
relationships you can really kind of get
caught up and trying to do everything
for someone else to where you kind of
really lose that attention to yourself
so I feel like after I got out of that
relationship I was able to actually
dedicate a lot more time to myself
because I didn't have all these you know
relationship related chores that I was
doing the worst thing that I've done so
please someone else would be that person
they need when they're lonely despite
the fact that I'm probably not their
number one choice I would have to I
would just be there for him even though
knowing that he doesn't love me in that
kind of way but I love him too much to
not say no to him
and I just wanted to be that person
that's always there for him so I would
put him first before myself and I just
get stepped on all the time
but in the end I even til right now I
think I believe that's fine because I
just can't leave him alone I love him so
much so I'll just be that person until
he read until he realizes or he doesn't
need me anymore and that's okay with me
you know yeah about three years ago you
remember me right
did Mike my ex-girlfriend we were
together four years I got the job of my
life you know I was you know but the job
that I could just be mr. piket white
picket fence the rest of my life you
know what I'm talking about and she
wanted to get engaged get married buy a
house do all that stuff and there was
something in me that said that's not
what you want that's what you think you
want you know what I mean your bank
accounts important you're like what you
can buy the car you drive you know those
things where what part of what area code
or what's what zip code in San Diego can
I afford that used to mean a lot to me
she you know when she was kind of saying
you know kind of twisting my arm saying
all right what's next in our life plan
well I said I don't want a life plan you
know I want to go see some stuff so long
story short we broke up because I mean
you know she asked me to do something I
didn't want to do and I quit my job and
I moved to Mexico and now I'm the
happiest person in the world I travel
the world I'm a professional nomad I
like the term journeyman journeyman is
kind of what I like and and that's what
I'm doing now and I got to tell you I
look back on that decision as the most
important decision I made in my life you
know what I mean so to answer your
question I totally didn't do anything to
make her happy but I did it to make
myself look happy that I don't know if
that fits your line of questioning I
kind of answered the opposite you got to
do what makes you happy because at the
end of the day you're gonna end up you
know these guys to end up having a
family and and when they didn't want to
or you know it's not what they wanted or
the woman they wanted you know then they
end up cross-dressing on the weekends
and having a secret life like that's how
those things manifest them
you know what I mean so you know you got
to have healthy everything's got to be
on line mentally spiritually physically
in this world you need to be doing the
things that make you happy so that's
kind of that's my take on that everyone
quick announcement have new idea for an
episode and it walks you guys so if
you're interested to people on Instagram
and wait for posts that will explain
everything that's pretty much it thank
you guys for watching and I'll see you
this Thursday
[Music]